you have to have a woman like represent
you what do you mean we're all seeking
we all want to align with people that
will
right but if my man like fails and stuff
it doesn't make me feel like less of a
woman let me let me tell you another
reason why women care about height it's
not just an evolutionary biological
thing because men who are taller or who
are physically larger are more capable
of protecting and providing for you it's
also a bit of a uh this is legit the
white fresh in fact
yeah
there's a social component too women
will perhaps be ridiculed oh you're with
a shorter guy I don't think that's right
but they might be ridiculed what are
they wearing they might be looked down
upon so women are just as much as men
are going to look to a line to men that
will kind of bolster their status to a
degree
if a man had actually here's another
thing women typically need a co-sign
from their female friends I don't know
if you guys can agree with this just as
like
you know the the only reason that these
bimbos are here these two is um they're
definitely promoting their only fans
they have a guy behind them telling them
to go on this show to get more sales
this girl doesn't even know how to hold
her face anymore look at how she's
holding her face in duck lips that is so
not natural she's been practicing that
women will seek advice from their female
friends they want to co-sign on a guy
whereas men we don't need to go to our
friends and be like hey what do you
think you know so much about women women
need you say women will do this he's not
wrong in that sense like a guy will just
like like his girlfriend and like if his
guy friends don't think she's hot it
doesn't really matter to him but to a
girl you have like your girlfriends in
your ear we've talked about this before
this no it's just not what do you mean
like like for girls I'm not saying I'm
saying that for guys I'm not saying it
for girls young girls I don't know but I
I've never you've never heard like with
girls where they'd be like oh you're
with him and then they'd be like oh like
I'm not no no like no I just I don't
know I'm saying how it is forgot yeah
I'm just saying it's it we don't really
care if we like somebody we like them
and we'll talk ourselves into the worst
jerk on the planet even if our friends
are like I don't know about him yeah I
know it is true it is interesting yeah
so he's not I don't think he's right
about that I'm not saying he's wrong
about everything but I don't think he's
right about that um
advice you don't be like hey this is my
girl like isn't she cute like no I don't
talk and that's another difference
between men and women you guys share a
lot of intimate details with your
girlfriends whereas we don't share
anything about our girl no nothing I
would never yo kid I would never like
with any of my guy friends I would never
like girls will disclose
girls will disclose to even casual
acquaintances the the size of the dude's
business you guys will share [__]
everything as long as this guy talking
about yeah I don't know I don't know
what this guy is talking about and you
know he's right that gentleman don't
share every single thing but low life
guys do they'll run around and be like
dude you're not gonna believe what she
did to me the other night I've heard
guys talk about women so crassly and
talk about their their body parts a girl
that they're so that they're telling the
girl they love her and they're out on
the street talking about her like she's
some cheap [__] well yeah but guys just
lie so he'll they'll say I love you to
like the girl they actually don't care
about but I'm maybe he is right maybe
the girl that you really do care about
you're not saying that kind of [__] I
don't know about the girl part where
it's like the girls are going around
sharing information because I don't
really think that's true but I don't
know I'm not a girl so who knows maybe
he's right there girls we'll talk we'll
talk about things uh together in a group
that are crafts but never about the man
that we are with and care about we keep
it private there's a little bit of like
a low key the protective nature jealousy
like jealousy thing that makes you not
give away every single you know secret
and I think that's what it is with men
when they care also but yeah well we
talk smack after the fact or of somebody
that we don't like dick was so tiny that
we don't like yeah absolutely that's
true
women you've interacted with and saying
girls will do this is not true women a
hundred percent not a hundred percent
women never mocked somebody's sizes I
didn't say Mock I'm saying women will
disclose very very very intimate details
about them guys don't do that guys show
each other girlfriends nudes like are
you I would never I would never I think
so with maturity it's different but like
that's high school is so different
you're a man that would do that
you have to talk about it yeah I know
you got to talk about it at different
stages of intelligence and maturity
because they're all right he's like I
would never do that but this lady's like
yeah this happens all the time and it
does you know where men are sharing
nudes and women show each other that
stuff too the fact that all that has
just become so normalized normalized is
gross in a whole other conversation all
right let's see what let's see what Mr
White has to say one of the things that
I've learned a lot about in the past
couple years is discipline get control
of your head control your mind and learn
discipline and so you stop talking
yourself out of things and so you know
Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we work with
I went through his 21 day challenge
where he gave me some tasks to do every
day and part of the challenge was to
wake up every day commit to doing it and
every time I started to talk myself out
of it I would have an excuse run through
my head some lame ass excuse and there
are four main excuses that he teaches
people that are that ruin lives that's
why we're doing the 21 Day Challenge
again together which Sunny is not
excited about because he's going to have
Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code sunnyfaz50 for a nice discount
and we'll be doing it with you guys
we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool
even tell they're women friends about
the girls that they've slept with in
full detail what their insides feel like
how wet it was yeah all this stuff
validation
we're not telling them because we want
validation what do you want from telling
other women the fit is killing me I've
never told a girl
do these pants make my butt look big
because you want that validation you
need to know that's not about men it's
not about men it's about women no I can
tell you right now I can count on two
hands and I'm not exaggerating one bit
the amount of men that I've been friends
with or that I've encountered in my life
that have talked about their life in
full detail and women that they've
they've how they've and how we're not
looking for approval out of it and women
are does it matter if you've talked to
yourself
yeah I'm not even enjoying this because
I feel like it's just this all this does
is highlight how gross we've become men
do this and women do this and it's like
it gets so cringy when it's like man no
men judge more no women it's like bro
shut up it's just stupid you actually
everybody that they're talking about is
an [__] because the fact that it's
gotten to where intimacy is just fodder
for a casual conversation in public what
you did how you did it how it felt what
it looked like what like like all those
details that used to just be private and
intimate and special are now talked
about with more casualness than what
someone had for lunch and it shouldn't
be crazy ain't it and this is why and
this is why you've you've got you know
you need a you know hundreds of
thousands of abortions every year
because these hoes out here it's crazy
man almost 700 people in the chat uh
okay I don't know how I'm gonna frame
this but one in the chat if you have
never disclosed to a man or a woman
hold on let me let me think I'm gonna
frame this okay one in the chat if
they're already gonna probably start
saying one one in the chat if you've
never gorgeous disclosed to a male
friend
intimate details see whatever you say
buddy this isn't a proper way to do this
we've I've had a man disclosed to me
intimate details about [__] woman
just because you won't doesn't mean that
other guys don't just because I won't do
it doesn't mean that or the girls don't
that's what I'm saying the exception but
I think he has a general point the
exception doesn't in general my guy
friends don't chat with their guy
friends like I chat with my girlfriends
like in general that's not the case with
everybody but I yeah
but I don't think girls are always
asking for advice or validation like
right there are times yes I have asked
for validation but there are also times
where I just want to talk about it
because it's yeah you just want to chat
yeah but like if if I'm talking about if
if a uh so if depending on the level of
if you're a lady there's no man friend
talking to you about intimate details
about another woman he's he's keeping
he's you know if you if you decide to
just become you know a skank or one of
the guys then you're gonna get that
conversation true but if you're yeah no
one's walking up to Kate Middleton being
like dude you know what I did last night
has not happened
yeah I mean so she seems pretty like
confident that um women talk about that
stuff more I don't know like I guess me
and my guy friends we talk about a lot
of stuff too but it's it's not about
like girlfriends I think that was his
point it's like your girlfriend you
don't say all that [__] about but like
you know some random Brad it's like why
do people do that it's whatever guy if
one of your girlfriends tells you like
oh he's kind of like he's kind of weird
or something it's done
it's done where it's like I'm not keep
that in your mind that how
any girl says oh I don't like him we had
a weird interaction five years ago you
will keep that in your mind permanently
Diane's actually like encouraged me
multiple times to give guys a second
chance see ya okay that that's but has
she ever but has she ever told you
stay away from that guy's no good
these guys are just now they're reaching
because now they were making these
statements like if a girl doesn't like a
guy or all you know excuse me if my
friends don't like a guy then I'm just
gonna walk away from him because they
don't like him it's one it's different
if a guy has been an [__] or creepy
or you know physical in a way that was
gross or for whatever reason he's an
actual low-grade human being he gave me
the difference but yeah I mean you know
it he's talking about two different
things that's a that's somebody looking
out for you like that guy I heard he's a
pedo like okay thank you for telling me
that I'm gonna keep my guard up when he
talks to me that's different I don't
think that's what they were talking
about no but that's kind of what he's
getting what he's the territory he's in
now to prove his point which doesn't
prove his point men we don't really need
like a co-sign for example if we're like
gonna go home with a girl or something I
don't go to bars on go to clubs I don't
really I don't drink occasionally I'll
have like a beer or whatever once maybe
three times a year I'll have one beer I
don't drink but if a guy's at the club
with his boys and there's like a girl
he's talking to like he'll just he
doesn't need to like check with this
male friends
up to him and said Hey listen my brother
was with her a couple years ago and he
caught crabs and herpes and a lot you
don't recommend it sometimes he would he
would probably go thank you that's that
is an intervention of danger that's what
that's where you would listen and you
would now need a co-sign and that's what
he's saying that you know girls do it's
the exact same thing he's he's just
trying too hard I've seen this guy show
before and I like them sometimes but
he's he's way off base right now sounds
silly you should just let this guy run
it look at this guy
so funny looking
um I don't know sometimes like if I'm
out like I'll ask my friends like
because like I'm shit-faced right right
it's different that's different I have
do I have bear goggles or is this is
this guy good looking you know is this
girl yeah
he's a drunk sex I'm like all right I'm
joking I'm joking I don't go out I know
men that do I see where you're coming
from yeah it's not for a co-sign it's
it's too yeah
not all we're not we're not getting
we're not looking for a cosine we're
looking we're like we're we're showing
our our the size of our balls basically
while you women while you women are like
should I go home with it hey do you
think this guy's cute when you go to the
bathroom hey should I go home you know
what I'm starting to agree with him more
because I've seen the girls interact
like that where they're like before they
go and like kiss a guy they like group
up like in a huddle almost like oh
should I do it should I talk to him like
it's not even her own decision it's the
decision of like the group so with the
guy it's not as important damn let me
let me Enlighten you so this isn't
necessarily approval of the guy this is
uh I'm about to act like a [__] and um
can you just give me the green light so
like I feel like it would not feel as
guilty about my about what skanky [__]
I'm about to do that's what that is you
go girl that isn't do you approve of him
it is can you just make me feel better
about the shitty thing I'm about to do
that I'm probably gonna regret tomorrow
that's what that is so he's
misinterpreting the body language and
the permission thing and the the sign
off all together
there's a very good chance that you will
not go home with him that's a good point
so so you're basically saying that if uh
if your guys if uh you're out with your
guys and you're talking to a girl and
you're feeling her right and you're
gonna take her home and the guys are
like oh man I don't know if you should
do that kid you're gonna be like dude
shut the [__] up what are you talking
about but if the girlfriend yeah cause
like I'll tell my boys like I'll be like
yo that girl is butt ugly man you're
shit-faced and then be like
but the com but again the question
should I do this is is for an entirely
different reason it really is about the
other part it really is about the should
I go with this person not should I do
this thing and help me feel better I'm
insecure and I can't make my own just
and I can't go do a horrible thing
without having my friends tell me that
I'm actually still a good person if I do
it that's what that's really about you
understand the distinction right you get
my point I think I do I think it also
comes from a safety precaution on our
end too because I'm not gonna let my
friend go home with somebody
throw the protection I'll throw the
safety out the window
we're talking about the looks and looks
alone we're women like a mother is he
cute enough to go home with we're
talking about looks we're not talking
about safety is he good-looking enough
for you to go home with him
we're not talking about that we're not
talking about that can have be an entire
different conversation by itself
you can separate it yes it's factored in
but we're just talking about one facto
right now like Let It Go ladies okay
okay you can't I can't stand people that
can't like just Converse intelligently
this is very hard to watch it's very
hard what do you like better the White
Russian fit or the black Russian fit
well they weren't in a contest but right
now if there was a contest Black fresh
and fit um are in the lead
it's just fresh and fit why are you
being racist
that's crazy
oh these are white friends I met both of
them
if the girl says hey babe I don't think
he's good looking enough for you you're
going to take that into consideration
and you might not go home with him
because what your girlfriend thinks
that has never once happened
to me now how old are you
have you been clubbing 19
yeah you've been to the clubs
you don't have to go to Club from
Minnesota
it happens a lot
I have an accent at all okay I've been
to the clubs in L.A and I've never once
asked for any of my girlfriend's
approvals on looks I've never needed to
do that I've never they're giving okay
well
I feel like we're getting away from I
don't even know what the original
the original conversation was sign off
so it's not for us it's not as much
about looks it's about does this guy
look like a creep
um tell me um you know another girl hit
me up they're real too do you want to
see yeah sure what what tea and I do I
get to look at today she is a very cute
normal girl who is not dressed like a
filthy skank
now they're all gonna text me be like
was she talking about me is this her
yeah
button all right maybe I'll have to fly
her out yeah let's talk to her that is
the first one I've looked at that I was
like okay which one are you talking what
that is the first one and all these
bimbos that you showed me she doesn't
look like a skank
thank you for reaching out to my son
thank you to the non-skank all right all
right well thank you so much for
watching drop a comment if you want to
see us go on the whatever podcast follow
me on Instagram and I'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings